il ya une autre question qu'on vous pose
c'est si l'état français est à la
hauteur sur les questions sur les
dossiers qui sont en cours notamment air
france klm
asko valforg ou encore alstom siemens
bruno le maire rencontre ce vendredi son
homologue néerlandais dans un premier
temps le ministre de l'économie avait
dénoncé une opération inamicale il est
revenu sur cette question ce matin on
l'écouté laissons la gouvernance d'air
france klm gérer les affaires et n'ayons
pas des états qui interviennent pour des
raisons politiques et qui au bout du
compte fragilise l'entreprise
la seule chose qui compte pour moi c'est
que l'entreprise soit solide qu'elle
dégage des bénéfices alors on a dit
bruno le maire était assez vindicatif
tapé du poing sur la table quand on
entend ça quand même
on a un petit peu du mal à le croire et
qu'on est on a du mal à croire à cette
fameuse phrase qu'il a dite je ne
baisserai pas les bras
comme on a du mal à le croire sur les
autres dossiers non non non non pas
vraiment je pense que le ministre de
l'économie actuelle est à l'image de
tous les ministres précédents ils ont
des sincérités qui changent d'une minute
ou d'une demi heure à l'autre et donc à
un moment il est scandaleux qu'un état
étranger l'injustice parce que moi avec
sa sincérité change c'est que on a des
gars là non mais ils sont là il n'ya pas
alors non je crois pas la cohérence de
sa police sa politique qui lui est pas
propre
ces fonds ce quelque chose d'assez
structurels au min de l'économie qui
sont succédé je pense par contre qu'il
est qu'il est sincère et qu'il a dans sa
volonté d'agir éculés et que sur le fond
moi je ne me choque pas que l'état dise
on doit on doit trouver une solution
la question heureuse de les chats non ce
qui me choque c'est que l'état
intervienne par contre que l'état dise
il ya des gens qui vont perdre un emploi
il ya dans le cas pas de deir france
mais dans la ford de blanquefort ya des
gens qui font perdre un emploi et si je
peux aider à retrouver un repreneur
je le fais ça me choque pas le rôle du
politique il est là aussi par contre la
seule pour moi ça veut dire juste aller
démarcher les investisseurs les aider à
les trouver
s'il peut le faire mais ça veut pas dire
allez mettre de l'argent ça ne veut pas
dire les maîtres d aide parce que cette
manière c'est juste prolongé un sas et
contre la conviction libérale mais ça
évidemment mais c'est ça va ça na votre
marché mais ça ne peut pas marcher
ça ne peut pas marcher si ça marchait si
ça marche et si si ça marchait si
l'offre était suffisante et est
convaincante
la demande serait déjà la voie là est la
vraie élevé elles ont été versés ford il
a quand même touché je crois au tour de
175 millions c'était des aides massives
donc les aides elles ont été données on
voit bien que ça n'a pas changé lors
questions c'est être assuré qu'ils
seraient subsidiaire céline qui n'a
justement parce que vous avez pris la
parole ok je comprends vos arguments et
je crois que là il ya une unanimité une
unanimité c'est décidément aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup de savonnage
pardonnez-moi autour de ceux de ce
plateau est ce que c'est votre avis
d'ailleurs dit que nous sur le fait que
vous ne voulez pas que l'état
intervienne
l'état nationalise est ce que pour
autant il faut pas qu'on revienne à
cette notion d' état stratège comme le
voulait notamment arnaud montebourg ou
les amitiés
la vraie question c'est qu'on a réussi
parfois notamment dans le cadre de
l'europe je me fais de la ceca dans le
canton a créé l'europe le fait de faire
l'europe du charbon et de l'acier était
un vrai objectif qui est à la fois
politique était souverain puisqu'il
permettait d'assurer une économie qui
répondait à une vraie problématique
était la problématique de l'énergie
aujourd'hui on voit bien dans toutes ces
affaires qu'on n'arrive plus à le faire
on vient de casser airbus ce contrat un
peu de se casser la figure dans
l'histoire de deux si mince
d'alstom on se dit mais bon sang il y
avait d'autres acteurs on aurait
peut-être pu réfléchir à une europe des
transports est en fait commencé à
regarder le monde en se disant
aujourd'hui on est sur des puissances
qui sont en déclin à l'inter de l'europe
l'europe pour être une vraie puissance
économique si elle arrête de faire du
sociétal si elle arrête de se mêler de
ce qui ne le regarde pas des moeurs quel
est ce un minimum de souveraineté au
pays et qu'elle se remette sur des
enjeux stratégiques et sur de
l'économique et là on n'a pas de levier
et on se plante
que ce soit sur klm air france que ce
soit on voit bien qu'il ya un vrai
problème de non je pense à pas
grand-chose à voir avec avec l'europe en
soit là ce qui est intéressant alors on
dit fort d'ascq ovale et air france klm
ces trois dossiers qui sont quand même
très différents qui sont situés à
différents et des problématiques
différentes le point commun c'est pour
ça que le projet
il fait beaucoup de bruit voilà voilà le
point commun c'est bruno le maire qui
fait beaucoup de bruit sur air france
klm par exemple on se rend compte que
les hollandais et deviennent français et
les français s'en offusque c'est à dire
que comme vous dites bruno le maire tape
du poing sur la table
ça passe pas inaperçu auprès de nos
voisins qui auront aussi des
participations dans des entreprises dans
lesquelles l'état à une participation
alors sur le fond ils sont un petit peu
inquiet sur la gouvernance d'air france
klm
ils ont un petit peu marre non mais ils
ont droit ils ont un petit peu marre sur
les syndicats français qui sont
intransigeants effectivement il ya un
problème de rentabilité entre les deux
partenaires donc un déséquilibre qui
s'est mis en place et l'état néerlandais
a décidé qu'il fallait rétablir un
équilibre en alcool non ça me plaît pas
parce que si vous voulez - ça pose la
question de la participation de régler
sa peau d'un glissement de participation
étape parce qu'en fait le problème se
pose parce que l'état français est
actionnaire d'ims france klm et du coup
on se retrouve avec un problème de
gouvernance un problème économique de
l'entreprise une crise maintenant
diplomatique un problème européen
donc au final est ce que vraiment le jeu
en vaut la chandelle est ce que vraiment
il faut que l'état participe passé entre
je voudrais que je me souviens qu'il
avait les
originaire landaise sur sept plateaux
puis on vous redonne la parole la parole
après m
quitte à passer pour un agent double
mais j'ai lu la presse néerlandaise
justement et la presse néerlandaise elle
nous renvoie un petit peu nous mêmes
c'est à dire que un état stratège état
stratège et 2001 je veux dire des
néerlandais en plus sale état stratège
qui a un excédent budgétaire 3 8% de
chômage a les moyens de sa politique
voyez ce que je veux dire est que demain
matin si les néerlandais veulent ils
peuvent racheter tout air france mais
comme ça en une journée
on rappellera quand même que c'est air
france qui a relevé qu elles mêmes je
parle de l'état non alors ça c'est ça
c'est aller ça c'est une légende urbaine
qu'elle sait pas du tout où la france
qui a remonté qu'à hélène et je vous
signale que actuellement les incas lm
perdez de l'argent il ya des stars
achetées aujourd'hui 80% des bénéfices
du trust sont amenés par klm 80% sait
pas lire tous à tous et toutes nos grève
d'air france rappelez-vous l'an dernier
écoutez c'est très simple c'est la
fourmi que cigale et la fourmi la fourmi
se trouve après dépourvu quand air
france venu c'est à dire que les pilotes
de la klm c'est aussi simple que ça en
ont marre de faire des efforts de
productivité
pour le syndicat des pilotes de ligne
d'air france ça c'est pour la partie
avant les choses par la france quelques
l on voit les néerlandais donc remonter
au capital royalement dans d'autres
dossiers les allemands défendre leurs
intérêts et leurs procédures même quand
la france accepte d'amputer une partie
de sa souveraineté pour fabriquer des
armes en commun ça c'est à retrouver
dans le figaro aujourd'hui voici ce que
notamment ces exemples inscrire au
député des hauts-de-seine et grand
promoteur de l'idée d'europe puissance
qui est me semble-t-il est de partager
sur ce plateau de jean louis borredon et
moi j'ai connu une europe au cours des
trente dernières années
ou quand on était en désaccord les chefs
d'état se réunissent et il s'entendait
bien le boss des études sous poids que
j'étais content d'être là et l'indicé
j'ai un problème et les autres disaient
comment on peut aider et on essayait de
trouver solution
là on a avec la hongrie avec la pologne
l affaire des hélicoptères en pologne
s'était aussi extrêmement brutale avec
l'italie avec les pays bas
on a une situation de tension qui est
extrêmement préoccupante et qui
correspond d'ailleurs à l'attention
qu'on observe à l'intérieur de nos états
nous avons un raidissement une
brutalisation des rapports
internationaux rose nous dit à l'instant
je pense que notre gouvernement
pardon ça saute je pense que notre
gouvernement se moque sincèrement du
sort des entreprises françaises et de
leurs personnels
moi je comprends la tristesse de notre
ami bourlanges mais maintenant comme le
dit dans l'opinion sur ce nom ce matin
le chef économiste philippe walter à
partir du moment où la chine des états
unis ne jouent pas le jeu de la libre
concurrence que bruxelles ne défend pas
les intérêts des pays européens et même
de l'europe puissance normal que chaque
état défendre ses intérêts oui oui mais
là où je suis pas d'accord avec jean
avec jean louis bourlanges c'est cci dit
qu'il ya une dislocation des des
intérêts européens en accusant notamment
les pays d'europe de l'est et les pays
bas c'est peut-être vrai sur la question
de sécurité ça fait longtemps donc mais
depuis qu'ils sont entrés je pensais que
on sait que l'europe de l'est et à un
tropisme beaucoup moins probable que
vous prononcez mais là aujourd'hui sur
la question pologne sol et que sur les
questions économiques sur les questions
économiques c'est si la france est dans
cette situation c'est parce qu'elle ait
donné des leçons de moral économique à
toute l'europe depuis des années alors
qu'on a un bilan économique qui est
catastrophique sur l'histoire des
hélicoptères pologne cela j'avais suivi
la sphère de créer moi je me souviens
des membres du cabinet de jean yves le
drian tonnant tonitruant contre les
polonais en les accusant de fachos je
cite à l'époque et je leur disais mais
les polonais on leur avait dit on avait
dit on leur vend des hélicoptères c'est
pour ça notamment qu'on arrête de vendre
les navires mistral aux russes et
mesures sapent dans ces cas-là on
reprend le contrat des navires mistral
avec les russes et ont dit aux polonais
vous avez préféré les hélicoptères
américains vous allez capteurs français
ben voilà nous on revient à nos contrats
pourquoi on ne fait pas ça pour quoi on
ne rentre pas dans ce rapport de force
d'intérêt national en fait on le fait
enfin je parle des polonais mais on peut
pas être l'italie l'année dernière avec
fincantieri et stx france justement où
l'un l'état à nationaliser
temporairement je peux dire que les
italiens se souvient non saber avoir un
italien sur ce plateau
il nous parlera est justement de
l'activisme
du brutalisme même français justement au
niveau économique on est les premiers à
faire ça on est les premiers on joue les
vierges effarouchées aujourd'hui et on
est les premiers justement à monter au
créneau
l'état français qui encore une fois à
table sur la table ont détecté un
problème il ya quelque chose donc je
pense que s'ils y aura ce problème en
europe la france en est responsable
et parce que c'est elle qui l'utilisent
comme une stratégie gouvernementale et
ça remonte pas à mâcon c'est un monde
bien avant c'est une philosophie
malheureusement une philosophie
politique française ne croire que
l'interventionnisme de l'état peut tout
régler plus compliqué que ça malgré tout
c'est qu'en fait on a quand même dès le
départ quand on a choisi d'élargir
l'europe et de l'élargir massivement
tous les débats à l'époque disait plus
vous l'élargisse et plus vous allez la
diluer et des accords à 28 vous
n'obtiendrez pas sur un certain nombre
de problèmes d'ailleurs on l'a vu même
sur l'euro on a été obligée de réduire
la voilure est de plus en plus on a dit
finalement l'élargissement se fera
contre l'approfondissement et de fait
avec l'élargissement n'a fini par tuer
la seule politique intégrée qu'on avait
en europe qui était à l'époque la pac
donc aujourd'hui on est en train de
pleurer et les mêmes sont en train de
pleurer sur des situations qui l'ont
installé à 28 ça va être un peu
compliqué d'avoir une europe puissance
surtout avec quand même des gens dont
les intérêts commencent à s'éloigner de
plus en plus juste je précise que pour
l'histoire de films quand il
6 justement nous avons eu ici en plateau
un italien
ce serait drôle c'est que sur les
nationalisations temporaires et moi je
suis pour je pense que c'est un outil de
souveraineté excellence appareils dès le
premier enfant 1 de ce qu'il a fait
c'était sarkozy en l'occurrence et qu'il
a fait dans un cadre très précis sur
l'intervalle de confiance après on peut
pas accuser les autres je verrai une
chose que non ça ça me choque pas mais
je la fais sur casino il ya quand même
une vraie différence là on parle de deux
pays je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
votre analyse sur l'approfondissement
mais on parle de l'élargissement et
l'approfondissement mais on parle de
deux pays fondateurs l'italie et les
pays bas
donc c'est quand même plus compliqué
mais dans cette affaire ne mélangeons
pas tout parce qu'on mélange rennes en
tout il s'agit là non pas du tout de
diminuer une compagnie européenne
il s'agit de rapports de force internes
au sein d'une commune puissances
européennes et qu'elle soit plus
néerlandaise opus française c'est un
autre sujet mais ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est dans notre
mentalité française si elle est moins
français c'est qu'elle est moins
européenne
regardez bien de raisonnement le
sophisme qu'on commet en permanence
c'est la souveraineté européenne veut
dire la souveraineté française
c'est ça les néerlandais ne le supporte
pas parce que ça fait 50 ans qu'ils se
tapent 7 c'est cette idée cela dit je
vous trouve pas une autre idée c'est à
chaque fois les français acceptent
d'amputer leur souveraineté pour
construire l'europe et quand il voit les
autres pays défendre leurs intérêts
nationaux il trouve qu'ils ne vous
passer totalement mais ça c'est
totalement faux les regards des biens
depuis par exemple euros comme accuse de
tous les maux en ce moment quel est le
pays qui s'endettent à si bon compte et
qui ne fait aucun effort
la france mais voilà donc arrêtons nous
profitons nous profitons au maximum
alors et là plus personne ne parle de
souveraineté quand il s'agit d'avoir des
taux d'intérêt à 0 5%
j'ai amassé mais rassurez vous un
message d'espoir vous verrez qu'il y
aura un accord entre les français les
néerlandais animaux on va redonner un
mot aux internautes et roanne avant de
vous rendre la parole est ce que vous
trouvez que l'état français gèrent mal
ces dossiers là et bien vous êtes une
large majorité à répondre oui à 75% pour
autant nicole nous dit ce n'est pas à
eux donc à l'état de gérer des
entreprises privées comme il se plante à
chaque fois ils devraient s'abstenir
donc ça devrait réjouir erwan le nom en
d'entendre un commentaire comme le vôtre
nicole le gouvernement français nous
explique languereau défendre notre
souveraineté nous intéressait génial
nous dit babineau pas pour nos voisins
brunetaud l'état n'est pas capable de
maintenir un bénéficiaire des
entreprises en situation de monopole
comment imaginer qu'il puisse redresser
des entreprises déficitaires
nationaliser temporairement et ridicule
nous dit minouche est de toute façon
lorsque les industries sont sont à ce
point rien ne peut les sauver
babineau encore air france grignoter
quel petit à petit le gouvernement
néerlandais rentrer dans le rapport de
forces c'est leur droit et nicole estime
qu'air france sera coulé par les
syndicats donc on peut comprendre que
les néerlandais ne veille pas être trop
lié air france
ça ça devrait réjouir christophe de
voogd les syndicats ont aussi leur rôle
à jouer il ne faut pas tout jeter une du
site
mais je vais rejoindre exactement ce
qu'ils faisaient ce qu'ils avaient de 10
sur les syndicats non ce qui est
souhaité dit avant mais sur les
syndicats aussi mêlée samedi ça sera un
autre débat de l organisation des
syndicats français leur légitimité et
armés et leurs horaires d'activité ils
ont évidemment un rôle à jouer dans une
vraie démocratie sociale ce qui est pas
la france mais pour revenir ceux qui
disaient vous internautes c'est ce qu'on
dit sur ce qu'on faisait sur air france
le problème d'air france depuis le début
depuis depuis des années c'est la
présence de l'état et saint jean à votre
question sur l'état stratège c'est ce
que l'état stratège existe non il n'ya
pas un seul exemple qui vous montre que
l'état stratège existe vous avez même un
rapport de la cour des comptes qui vous
dit qu'ils ont deux problèmes les tas de
problèmes
1 il est encore plus rapaces que les
fonds que les autres font ils demandent
ils à des taux de ils demandent les
dividendes de ses participations qui
sont absolument extraordinairement élevé
et il n'a pas de vision il a pas de
vision donc on arrive à on arrive à des
échecs permet
régulier de l'état stratège parce que ça
ne fonctionne pas bien c'est sur ces
paroles certes article de foi donc de
hermann notant qu' on abandonnera
sociaux est-elle d'éléments bien entendu
d'arguments en tous les cas et le débat
continue il ya un autre débat qui est
lui prêt sans est qui qui préoccupe
énormément les français d'après ce que
révèle le sondage qui sera à lire et
retrouver ce soir dès ce soir sur
lefigaro.fr
faut-il rapatriés